Arita estamos hablando service Americana
[Music]
you're on the beach this is what you
want you don't want any of that like Bud
Light [ __ ] um it doesn't really taste
like anything which I sort of enjoy oh
okay
it feels like a penny the entire flavor
lasts for about 15 seconds on your time
Sol which in Spanish means Sun this
seems like knockoff Corona come on board
it was like a P vibe I'm getting on this
one PP it's cardboard II wha this is
like a little cidery Bud Light is a
little aggressive compared to this to be
honest to me this is not taste good at
all this is like like a Mexican Guinness
okay that's got more Kotak the way
different
that's caramely Modelo but Dad I love
this is like the chod of beer bottle
it's short and stout unfortunately you
can't be classy when you open this beer
talk about making you angry when you're
supposed to be enjoying your barbecue
I'm not saying cigarettes are cool kids
cuz they're not but I'm just saying the
badassery that comes with it is here in
a medela not for me tastes like weed
[ __ ] good it's really [ __ ] good I
was gonna use the bottle opener but
Takata is I like see it and I trust it
it has like trust words that's it if I
can trust the Reds that's fine
these are the worst that is smooth
that's the smoothest one we've had so
far
okay it's like what you were hyping it
up so much I like it this one's more
bitter than the others Victoria yeah it
tastes like nothing to me
that's a nice beer beer I like this beer
I like it
they're all good this one's best tie
between Corona and Modelo Modelo yeah it
was the best one for sure if I'm like
already really drunk I'm gonna go for
sole but this one tastes like cider so
I'm a big fan
I like Modelo cuz it actually tastes
like beer I like nice la victoria I like
Victoria I like the name of it I know
why Coronas the most popular Mexican
beer it really does taste the best this
is the best one India is my favorite
good ona is my favorite god booze Modelo
is that oh it's mine
get in get in here we're cheersing
[Music]
okay cheers Cheers Justin